hi everybody my name is Nikolai I am
from Russia st. Petersburg and I will
tell about
application Diagnostics under the hood
first of all sorry from English instead
of improving heat I spent a lot of time
under the hood with debuggers I work at
grid dynamics and full stack developer
and in the retail domain we do digital
transformation for logic a u.s.
ecommerce companies using non GS and in
order to create our session successful
we devote a lot of time to diagnostics
and today not just no.6 has a working
group that deals with performance
profiling tracing memory analysis and
post-mortem debuggers and to understand
where we are now in Diagnostics I
suggest you look at as a timeline as a
history way I put the appearance of
significant tools and highlighted
several stage the first stage of course
starts from 2009 where Naja's was
presented at GS con cool but the part of
people instruments appeared before
synergist so as a sister profiler system
profiler dtrace pair of instruments and
they still in use
after the nigiri appearance began to
appear tools from the first stage keep
down memory Road not inspector and
basically those tools will develop
effective in development and not in
production and also do you remember
there was a fork IGS which world more
appeal is that not just itself so
community was divided but since 2015
IGS and not just you need uniting the
fourth version community has a clear
retro of development and by this point
not already used in production by large
companies such as eBay Alibaba Amazon
and by our customers as well and here is
a need for debugging and profiling tools
in production will create flame graphs
for profiling and C++ debuggers were
adapted for
Nagi as debugging so only in the second
stage we've got the ability to debug and
profile in production but we were there
in the first stage already and it was
funny and painful so from the 2005 17 I
have highlighted
the first stage on the timeline which is
mostly focused on improving Nadia's
performance tracing in internal
components and improving the quality of
instruments here is a significant
tradition to turbofan appearance of a
sink hooks so looks like the death today
we have a lot of useful heat tools but
most of them still are external and
require a better functionality with the
less performance overhead and summarize
the pass in Diagnostics not GS was
mostly focused on performance and there
were reasons for that we often didn't
have enough functionality and each time
we transition to new version of Nijs we
faced it with the fact that we lose
support of many useful tools so we had
to choose either we go with a new
version which is faster but we lose
support of useful tools all we stay with
old slow but with the tools and other
applications not just applications web
UI began for front-end and microservices
allocated in the center of large
enterprise architecture where integrate
we use a multiple systems such as CDM
different databases services and problem
can come here from anywhere and in the
days of high load such as Black Friday
when company make a huge profit each
code each meet each mistake costs
thousand dollars per minute and if there
is an error in Nadia's application is
necessary to choose a strategy and tools
as soon as possible and prepare the hard
fix and today I will show you how to do
that in certain examples in case of
errors performance loss and memory leaks
in production so let's go to the
debugging there are several reasons for
debugging in production uncut exception
kill your process physical reproducible
errors and you don't have enough
information from your logs and and
actually you cannot lock everything
production environment features and the
error does not reproduce locally and you
don't have a time let's
moving to the simple example we have a
controller which call service at work we
use the REST API and the error if thrown
in the controller and application
crushed and here is a simple
implementation of product reservation we
have a product controller with the
reserved method where user profile and
reverse account data I extracted from
the cookies and since some user doesn't
have reverse account application Thrones
and error your application crush and
sauce it's bad but if it sells a flag
about an architect section in case of
uncut exception Nijs who create quorum
which he is a whole which is dump of
whole memory of the process that
contains heap dump and stack trace
before the crash after that your
application restarts you get access to
production to the dump and read it with
the debugger the most relevant today is
LLL not plug in for l-ltp debugger so
and to find the error we need to do just
three simple steps so we need to get the
stack trace and finds the last
JavaScript operation on function and
read the source code of this function
and get the input parameters request and
the response so let's repeat it with the
core dumps we have a core dump and to
read it we need to run ll node and
specify the path to the dump after that
in debugger session we get access to
reach the trace with the common two 8bt
which is a back trace and that here we
need to find the last J's function which
is store it in 6 frames frame and here
we see this is a reserved method of our
product controller and we have addresses
to this object
incoming message which is a which is a
request response and even to the
function source code in the memory so we
need to read the source code of our
functions or less just gets address and
using command v8 inspect prints source
with a dress on function we get the
source code of this function out of the
memory after the reading source code
letter
Jim back to the start race and get the
address of our request and extract from
the memory and here it is so this is our
request we did it with the common to
eight inspect and use it address of
request and after that we can repeat
this common together cookies to figure
out which profile doesn't have rewards
and wipe our application across so
that's pretty simple but it was a good
stack trace informative decrees and
because we had all necessary information
we had order of last functions with
addresses to the request response or all
object but sometimes a framework error
handler or incorrect customer error
handling makes a trace uninformative
consider this at the next example so
here instead of pass exactly and rewards
ID we accidentally positive whole
rewards object and now the error is
wrong in the surveys in a synchronous
mode and we don't have a cache block
here to catch the error and to catch it
we use a subscription to an hello to
rejection event where we will do process
abort to crash we use to get the dump
and when we try to gather stack trace of
this dump
we will not find any find anniversary
information so we don't have requests
respawns and needed functions so we
don't have a stack trace and in this
case we need to you work just with the
heap dump with the memory and I'll show
you how to do this first of all we need
to get the requests from the memory and
we can find objects by the type using
common fine J's instances and specify in
comic message so those are requests in
the dump in the memory but while there
are so many and which request crushes
the process with all other requests that
will there inside the event loop and how
to find it
and in this case we use a unique request
ID which we store in the header even
extraction ID to find the right one and
we can get this value from our logs and
find which object has has a reference to
the string to this value with the
comment find revs - - drink and we have
a headers object so let's find the
parent object of this header and using
command v8 find revs value and others of
headers we found the incoming message as
a request that we need hi Dave so that
was easy let's go deeper and imagine
that this data is not enough on us for
us and we need to know
local variables from other other
functions for example from the reserve
service where was request REST API and
request database and results we'll
assign it to the same local variable
data and we don't have any objects
referencing to this data how to find it
but we can find this object by values of
its properties for example by reverse ID
user ID or by even by the name of some
property for example reverse and store
so the main idea is here that we can
find the objects not only from the last
function before the crash we can get
them out of memory from all other
functions with high probability that
were executed before the crash from
sample from middleware from policies
from controller or other storage service
and storage and it helps a lot and to
get more information we can use an odd
report and in fact the search for an
error it's like a data to investigation
where after generated before the crash
report will say you what happened with
your process by JavaScript and C++ stack
trace where it was and under what
conditions by worker of garbage
collector memory and CPU and logs will
give you valuable hints
but core dump is not a silver bullet and
to create core Dom on each error is not
a good idea
otherwise the picture will be like this
we have a lot of errors in production
and you know the spell not a bottle and
cut exception so let the debugging begin
for each error is created core dump
one core dump took her down freak or
damn a lot a lot a lot of core dumps and
bam and your boss is waiting for you and
he asked she asked hey buddy will lose
money how much time you need to solve
this issue and you think him where is my
dump so I call the situation core dump
flood where is the problem we need to
have we need to follow to error handle
best practices to have a central asset
error handler with error selection logic
for example I have a hearty producible
error but I don't want to generate
hundreds of identical core dumps and
look for them among other all I don't
want to create core dump and kill the
process every time on error when I can
handle it
and in this case I use the gen core and
error registry which is a custom error
selection logic which makes decision
should it create core dump a was for
this error dump craters already or is
this a heart irreducible error and if it
should we use a gem core that makes fork
of you of your main process and
terminate it with the dump and our main
process continue serving traffic without
accident so that's pretty cool enough
and let's reduce the whole algorithm
what last time so if the error is not
cut not just application generates core
dump not report generates report and
application restarts the continue
serving traffic but if the error was cut
error handler pulled the available
information to a log
and error selection logic make decision
should it crush the process should have
generate a core dump and if not it
continue serving traffic and handles the
error and if it should it use GM core to
make a process fork to terminate it with
the dump and our main process continue
serving traffic so after that we just
connect to production get local look and
our core down to the bucket we ll not is
it so my suggestions follow to error
handler best practices call abort only
in one place in central hazard error
handler usage angkor do not kill your
main process and use a non report to
have more information in case of
unexpected crush track your ID using
request IDs for example X request ID
from engineering or Zipkin headers and
avoid core dump flood that was about
debugging in production so let's go to
the performance profiling and search for
memory leaks and let's investigate the
performance loss and memory leaks at an
example of well real situation when
after the one of the religious we had a
huge performance decline just before the
Black Friday Eve and to do to figure out
was where as a problem we can start with
performance profiling using internal
profiler of Nijs and tick processor to
find the longest separation but there is
a there is a good graphical
representation of profile at trace its
attacks its call it flame growth and the
main idea of the feed to find the
wireless block because the wider block
is them often it was during is a
sampling CPU so the long gate what
performative and on high-level overview
we can find that application spends 10
percent on the retrieval data from 8
I 20% unload operation with data and the
longest block is a server-side page
rendering it's about 65% of time and
it's a lot because it can't East consist
from custom helpers partials and tea
plates templates with logic and if we
scroll up we will see which operations
are on CPU here is handlebars and is low
- Mary utils and let's go deeper to low
- merge stacks and if we zoom in we will
see so there are two white blocks of
flow - base merge operation base merge
deep clone the for each cycle and for
data processing of product matter so we
found that our helpers logic in team
played a lot of cycles low - utils
our performance is the cause of lowest
performance
it's our bottlenecks and to improve that
we can we did performance profiler with
a pair of 0 x pcc tools and what we did
we reduce the punitive operations since
it blocks our they block our main
process long cycles decent Parslow -
object merge and remove it logic from
buting place and helpers especially
custom halters and gradually implemented
server-side rendering and after those
all improvements all the server-side
rendering expands only about 15% of main
time and we reduce it wild blood and
increase it our synchrony of application
execution so my suggestions performance
should be part of requirements every
time if you would like to add some
library third party library or your
library you need to measure performance
before and after every time collect the
measurement result or heap
and profile on different environments on
stage environments and maneet or
diagnostic tools performance impact but
misfortune never comes alone and with
performance loss we have a problem with
his memory consumption and there are
many ways how to define memory leaks we
can do it with application monitoring
tools like an solid New Relic DTrace
perf compare heap dump but I suggest you
to focus on excessive garbage collection
since it makes negative impact on
performance
look at this nearly graph the GC rate
grows in a new space young generation
and to get more information about
garbage collection work we can trace it
using tracers GC flag of Nadia's and
here we see that not said memory
consumption grows after each collection
and interval between collection is too
short that means that it's difficult to
find to find them in the memory so and
garbage collection performs very
frequently and by the duration of
garbage collection we see there are 16
16 milliseconds 17 and the more than one
default millisecond so it that means
that garbage collection spend more time
together objects in the memory because
of complex topology complex graph of
objects in the memory and it spend more
time to kalam the memory and how to
track which operations require memory
allocation and as we know Naja's
profiling result receipts tax it's a mix
of JavaScript function and native v8
functions so why not just keep track way
back from garbage collection functions
calls to JavaScript so let's look at a
simple implementation of flame graph
and on the left side where CMS helper
did insert it use string replies which
required memory allocation from you one
use drink and after that since memory
allocation was failed garbage collection
called collec garbage and what we can do
we can find scavenge objects law look at
text representation command and figure
out by way back which JavaScript
function required memory allocation and
clean at lamps memory so and same as
helper is a problem the same example
with the product matter which did the
map of big array and since it required
memory for new items and garbage
collection called
scavenge object and allocation step so
as I said we would use it
our mappers clones be good JavaScript
cycles and custom helpers and in the
result after that our memory can doesn't
doesn't grow and garbage collection is
little more than one default millisecond
but we think it's ok and the same
problem was in in all generation where
he is a long garbage collection and to
find miss it closures or timers usually
we use the heap dump we compare them but
I'll show you how to do the same with
the core dump in case of fatal error
when you get the core dump so what we
need to do we need to get a report of
all JavaScript object inside the memory
we can do it with comment we ate find
objects GS objects and incoming mass
large of incoming messages look
suspicious so let's figure out where
those requests allocated so we need to
get all of them from the memory choose
the first one for example and let take a
look where are these request is located
so
this is a reference from server responds
to requests and from one big array so
let's figure out where is this array
located and this comment we ate find
revs value and address of this array we
can find the parent object and this is
profile middleware with the request
property so we found which object holds
memory my suggestions controls the
lifecycle of objects so you need to know
where your object was created and where
to it will be removed trace work of
garbage collector and if you have if
you're not sure about the behavior of
JavaScript behavior maybe in case of
closures you can download and use d8
which is the debug 8 4 we ate and check
the JavaScript behavior called
JavaScript manually or read a memory
usage test using leakage and create heap
dump and core down to investigate and
find the problem
so finally we lose performance with
growth of functionality until it became
critical for us and after all in all
those improvements we achieved in
increasing our performance by half from
the original baseline and to prevent a
situation like this one you can choose
my tips my suggestions because not GS
was created as a fast performance
platform and we as end users should
develop fast performance applications
that's all thank you
you